Palestinians and Janine pay their
respects to nine people killed in an
Israeli military weight on the occupied
West Bank on Thursday they are buried
next to dozens of other Palestinians who
died over the past year in Israeli
incursions into the Janine refugee camp
this is the first time Israeli forces
have stormed the narrow Alleyways of the
Janine refugee camp in the past several
months according to locals their past
trades were limited to the outskirts
people here woke up to a pitched battle
between Israeli army forces and
Palestinian fighters in this road in the
densely populated camp
aign
I was leaving for work at seven in the
morning I looked outside soldiers were
coming out of four cars they took over
this house here and another rooftop and
started shooting at the Fighter's house
for half an hour after which they shot
anti-tank weapons at the place that's
when we believe the fighters were killed
families here are frustrated and
exhausted because these Israeli military
raids have become regular parts of their
daily routine and they say they stay up
late every night fearing the next
military raid and they started asking
this question when will it be my turn
Fatima job lives next to a house that
was raided she says for months she and
her family have been living in fear of
being killed injured or paralyzed
it was a battlefield I couldn't move in
my house because it overlooks the
shooting I stayed in the inner rooms I
couldn't even go to the toilet if I
needed to I'm terrified
one of the victims of this new raid was
a 61 year old woman locals here say she
was shot dead in the neck by Israeli
forces on the rooftop of her home
the rubble of this house and its charred
walls bearing witness to what's become a
new daily nightmare for Palestinians
Engineers
refugee camp